- Hey guys, San Francisco here.
Got out of New York
before the storm
and made Alan here, our CFO,
cancel his trip to
London and basically this is
going to be, you know, a lot
of people been talking about
different looks for DailyVee.
This will be a different look.
I'm gonna sit here now and we've
been sitting here for an hour,
hour and half and gonna sit
here for the next 5 to 7 hours.
Really looking at the financial
impacts of our business.
You know we're
running Vayner X with
PureWow and VaynerMedia
we're talking about over a
$150 million entity and
so there's a lot of work.
There's a shitload of
Excel sheets here that I'm not
necessarily interested in but
the work has to be done and when
you get this scale
you get to 800 people,
there's a lot of inefficiencies.
Especially when you're building
culture and so I'm just looking
at the financial
impacts of the business.
So this is about as
boring, this is not selfies.
This is not fun
quotes in an interview.
This not the stage.
People rushing it.
This is not DRock waving his
fucking hand in the camera.
This is fucking real work,
the true life behind being a
CEO of a big company.
GaryVee, DailyVee
these are my side hustles.
This is what I do for a living
so I'm gonna bore the fuck out
of you in today's episode.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Best I Can" by Rowlan)
Too many meetings.
That's what it is, Claude.
That's what's killed us.
Everybody needs
more people 'cause
everybody's in everything.
I don't know. I'm debating
everything right now.
Alright, let me keep workin'.
Cool.
Small company where he could
have huge impact and huge say
because he didn't
have the patience,
he had zero patience.
The two interactions
I had with him I was like,
"Brother, you've
got to pay your dues.
"You know,
that's what we all do."
You know, and the
lack of patience I think...
Hey guys, it's Gary.
Everybody on?
Okay, great.
Alan and I are sitting here,
we're going through everything.
What I want to do on Monday's
off-site with this group
I want to leave
with basically...
How does hiring
and freelancing...
Just in the mezzanine of the
W in San Francisco
running a business.
That's how we do it.
If you haven't seen the video
I made for all 22-year-olds with
Taylor from episode 244
of The #AskGaryVee Show,
please DRock, Tyler,
have some videos right now.
Actually, put the
video right in here.
Anyway, make sure you watch it.
It is straight fire.
Awesome, see ya.
Alright, bye.
I mean this is great.
Fucking love this.
This is it.
You know how I talk about the
battle scars and the blood in
the mouth and loving it.
This is what's
happening right now.
There's plenty of battle
scars and blood in the mouth.
But I love it.
You know, it's hard core
lot of political feelings.
Everybody's protecting their
worlds and trying to advance and
all this but that's the
shit job I have because
the buck stops with me.
All problems on this guy.
I want you to edit this very
smartly which is for example
this call with...
Hey, so April 1st...
Music, music, music,
you're capturing everything.
It just all goes fast, slow.
Slow down, hey
April 1st, cut. Got it?
Like words until it,
words until it's not words.
Got it?
You're filming all of it.
Want everything straight fast,
even when it's a bad angle,
you're fast.
You stepped away didn't
get my whole head there, fast.
Got it? Words.
("Best I Can" by Rowlan)
Hey, so I've got, great.
I've got all the context...
You should call her.
Okay. Love you, man.
See ya, bye-bye.
Actions louder than words.
My preference would
be to get to you ASAP,
preferably when the Royals are
at home so I can watch some of
my fantasy baseball
players play that night.
That'd be fun for me.
Plus, I'm gonna bring Marcus
who I'm gonna beat in fantasy
baseball this year so
it'd be nice to have him there
and make fun of him.
So let's try to get a date ASAP.
(laughs)
Maybe you'll work with,
Marcus or Dennis and then my
assistant Tyler and we should
try to get there in the next,
within the next 30 days.
Does that sound right?
You guys there?
Hey, so guys, real quick,
I think that there's
going to be a
remarkable product in your
two worlds of consulting and
now this Vayner (censored)
that you're gonna be doing.
And I think it's historically
sat under the way we've thought
Dennis of
consulting but now that
(censored) gonna be doing...
("Hold It Down"
Rowlan Ft. Jonezin)
You're hungry, right?
You're not used
to rolling like I do.
Have you done your bracket?
'Sup brother?
Can you set a meeting for
30 minutes for me
as well with you...
$25,000...
Give you more
detail if I have to.
Can we get a pad and pen?
You got a pad of paper?
You do? That's amazing.
That's awesome.
So I go pen to paper when
I get really fuckin' serious.
When I'm doing like hard core
work or getting ready for a
fantasy baseball draft.
That's about the only time.
- What are you laying out?
- The org.
Laying out the org, so right,
what are my direct reports.
- I'm an architecture student at
Texas Tech University and
even though that's art based--
- Sure.
- really designed based, not so
business but obviously there's
business everywhere.
I really want to strive
and I'm like (inaudible).
What are those steps?
It's exciting.
I didn't think,
wow, that's so cool.
- I'm glad we
got to meet, man.
- I seen you and
I was like no way.
- Real pleasure.
How are you?
- [Woman] Nice to meet you.
- How are you? I'm Gary.
Nice to meet you.
Awesome, man.
Thanks for saying hello.
- For sure, for sure.
Any advice that'd you give
someone today 22 years old?
- I mean, you know my spiel.
- Of course.
- [Gary] There's only
two things that matter.
Hard work and patience.
You're a kid.
But it's great that
you've realized that
it's gonna take actual work.
That's it, man. Just grind.
Never get down on yourself.
Put in the work. It takes time.
But it's super achievable.
It's all within yourself.
It's you verse you.
- Like you say the only person
that can stop you
is yourself, right?
- 100% by worrying
about what other people think.
You know?
- Yeah, that's true.
- That's it.
- That's true. Why not?
Hey, sorry to bother you.
- Such as pleasure, no worries.
- Thanks so much, man.
- Appreciate it.
- I wish you well. Bye-bye.
("Hold It Down"
Rowlan Ft. Jonezin)
So we now have a full name for
the Vayner internal day.
Daily, I got to get it down.
Where it says the
Daily Digital Deep Dive,
I want that all to be the same
font and the same way and then
all the D's in the
name to be green. Got it?
Either, no worries, no worries.
Either pick the first
font or the second font.
You know what's amazing when you
actually build a culture first,
we're literally doing
insane things in four minutes.
Yeah, that's the beauty.
There's no reinforcing.
Of course, you won't need to.
You know?
- [DRock] (inaudible)
you're building a culture.
- So guys, I'm sitting
here and I'm talking to Alan.
Let's show Alan.
And Alan has been a remarkably
successful corporate CFO
and I think his last
P-and-L that he ran was
a $500 million holding company.
It's not his
first fucking rodeo.
We're doing a lot of stuff here.
I told him like, you
know we're just talking.
DRock said, "I want
more insight on it."
Here's very simple.
When you build culture,
this is why Honey first.
Honey Empire
instead of empire of honey.
When you have a Honey Empire and
your direct reports are blindly
bought in 'cause you've done
everything right to prove them
to trust you, you can
do big structural changes,
big strategy
changes, big re-org,
big fundamental.
If I emailed my direct reports,
my leaders tomorrow and said
we're now selling actual honey.
Like we are no longer an
agency, we now produce honey.
I just bought a honey
farm in Paso Robles and
we now sell honey.
I just think 80%
of them would be like,
"Okay, what am I doing?" Yes.
Yes, so when you build
culture and you build trust
you can go fast.
You can do things fast.
We're about to do six months
worth of work politically in
six hours and that's special
and that's the difference
and that's how you win.
And that's where
big companies die.
And when you start
getting into nine figures,
$100 million-plus you get bigger
and you get slow.
When you're the CEO,
you got to have
that buy-in from your
constituents to be able to get
the shit that you want done.
And on the flip side,
a lot of corporate CEOs
spend too much
time worrying about the politics
and their constituents which
then creates non-action
which then creates failure.
For me, I know I'm gonna get 9.3
out of 10 constituents on board
with what I'm about to do
and the 0.7 won't be here.
There's just no options.
Have to win.
'Cause speed's
part of the equation.
- [Alan] That was good.
- Yeah, I'm basically
making a show
for the 19-year-old me.
I basically am
creating DailyVee,
this is the show
I would've watched at 17,
16, 19, 22 and be like oh, oh.
And the growth, the growth I'm
getting from people on email.
I know you see it.
'Cause the game's
gray and everybody thinks
it's black and white. You know?
- [Alan] True.
("Hold It Down"
Rowlan Ft. Jonezin)
Daily Digital Deep Dive,
Daily Digital Deep Dive.
Daily (laughs) Digital
Deep Dive.
Alright, here we go.
That's very nice.
What up Instagram?
It's me, Gary.
I know Daily Digital Deep Dive.
Daily Digital Deep Dive.
We finally came up with a
name for our VaynerMedia all day
immersion in New York City.
- [DRock] The 4-D experience.
- The 4-D experience.
4-D experience,
you like that, huh?
- [DRock] Love that.
- The 4-D experience,
Daily Digital Deep Dive.
8 A.M. 'til 7 P.M. in
New York City. $10,000 a head.
$10,000 a head.
We're debating between 10
and 12 people for the day
and I'm excited about it.
So I know a lot of you have
already signed up from Instagram
and I'm excited to
see you guys there.
I'm not in New York
as you can see, no snow.
I'm in San Francisco.
Body Coach, good to see you.
So what have you
learned about your failures?
Angelo, Angel,
I like my failures.
I don't know, I learned
whatever the fuck I needed
to learn in that situation.
Try not to do it again.
You know what's
interesting about failures?
A lot of people make the same
ones over and over and over.
It's just such a DNA thing.
Anyway. How you guys doin'?
Back in London in a month or so.
Good to see you Ins.
How many of you guys are in
for the Daily Digital Deep Dive?
How many of you
are coming to that?
signed up for the email?
You're getting an email any day
soon from me with the details.
$10,000 a head.
I know a bunch of you
are coming to do that.
Wanted to get a sense
of how many of you are in.
Scotty's in. Alright, Scott.
Oh yeah, by the way,
real quick for all the
people that sign up now,
by the way email me
at Gary@VaynerMedia.com.
I'm gonna do it that way now.
Oh, Tyler,
185 is exporting, nice.
Great to see you, man.
Good to see you again, man.
- [Man] You too.
- No, are you nuts? Every time.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Take care,
good to see you, man.
Continued success.
Guy I invested in, his
company, three years ago.
I like to talk shit.
Beat everybody 167-159.
That's great. Problem is--
- What's good to
score a touchdown?
- No, no I'm in it for 167
to 159 in a basketball game.
Problem is I'm
not in for 167 to 173.
That's a loss.
So because of the
state of the company
all of those things have
to ladder up into you because
that's what you do for a living.
I mean, no you don't have to
film any more of this dull,
deep thinking, operations.
Well I agree it's not dull
especially for us business nerds
but this is a
good time to wrap up.
This way you can edit
and make it real cool.
There's a lot of editing
the way we want to do it.
At least the way
I want to see it come out.
Are you gonna edit it?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Want to go and
start editing? Go edit.
We got more work to do.
More Excel sheets.
See ya. Good.
- [Man 2] Is that Gary?
- Yes.
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Hi.
- Hey.
- Can I get a picture with you?
- Of course.
- Are you really from Belarus?
- I am. How about you?
- Baku.
- Baku, very cool, man.
Real pleasure.
(speaking Russian)
- Yeah, okay.
- Alright, awesome.
Yep, you got it.
How are you?
- Good. How are you?
- Very good.
Awesome, take care guys.
Take care.
(speaking Russian)
Alright, now you can go.
("Hold It Down"
Rowlan Ft. Jonezin)